yeah so candidate calls typically I mean
for 10 a day and that's irrelevant as
well right it's not a case of just
registering somebody that isn't really
relevant to what we've got going on or
wasting time on that phone calls
typically trying to do two or three a
day trying to get specs out consistently
good quality CV so making sure every
resume that we're sending or every CV
we're sending if the client picked me up
and asks me why I've sent that person
making sure I could talk to the reasons
why in my thought process what do you
aim for your CV to interview ratio
typically to be should interview by one
and every two people we're trying to put
together a short list of probably eight
people and expect half to get the
opportunity to interview
[Music]